es algo que nadie esperaba y que ha
dejado conmocionados a los locales en
mitad de la noche un misil impactó en
suelo polaco a tan solo 6 kilómetros de
Ucrania en lo que parece un fallo del
fuego cruzado en la Guerra de Ucrania y
que se saldó con la vida de dos
agricultores
al principio pensé que se trataba de la
explosión de un horno pero luego resultó
que había caído un misil me puse pálido
me dijeron que esos hombres estaban
muertos podría haber sido yo ese podría
haber sido yo
ahora la pregunta que muchos se repiten
es quién lanzó ese misil que terminó en
Polonia las autoridades polacas han
dicho que es muy probable que fuera la
defensa ucraniana y lo calificó como un
desafortunado incidente
lo que ocurrió fue que un cohete impactó
nuestro territorio no fue intencional no
fue un misil dirigido a Polonia el hecho
es que esto no fue un ataque contra
Polonia
Y es que las pruebas iniciales parecen
indicar que Rusia no nada que ver con lo
sucedido algo que Moscú ha sostenido
señalando directamente a Ucrania por el
tipo de misil utilizado las fotografías
de los restos encontrados en el pueblo
de chebble Fueron identificadas
inequívocamente por expertos militares
de rusos como fragmentos de un misil
antiaéreo de un sistema de defensa aérea
ucraniano s-300 afirmación
no obstante el organismo sostuvo que la
responsabilidad final sigue recayendo
sobre Rusia por sus ataques contra
Ucrania
pero Déjenme ser claro Esto no es culpa
de Ucrania la responsabilidad final
recae sobre Rusia ya que sigue con su
guerra ilegal contra ucranes
Aunque Polonia confirmó que no invocará
el artículo 4 de la otan que prevé
consultas entre los miembros en caso de
amenaza la alianza transatlántica
asegura que se mantendrá vigilante
advirtiendo que lo ocurrido demuestra
que la guerra crea peligros para su
territorio